i think when people started to discover
that we're able to function virtually
maybe we don't need our offices anymore
they're taking for granted a that the
pre
the relationships pre-existed that the
trust pre-existed that's number one
number two we're also starting to
realize that being at home
by ourselves or with our families the
whole time like
i actually would like to leave the house
you know
um and you can't really have a great
brainstorming session over zoom it just
doesn't work you know
there's something about being in person
and i think one of the things that
people fail to recognize is that running
a virtual organization is actually
way more difficult than running an
in-person organization and the reason is
because trust doesn't happen in the zoom
room trump trust doesn't happen in a
meeting
trust happens between the meetings isaac
stern the virtuoso violinist
said trust uh he said music is what
happens between the notes
and trust is the same trust happens
between the meetings it's
when you're filing into the into the
conference room and you're like hey
steve hey bob
you know it's that's like hey i heard
your dad was sick oh yeah he's doing
much better thanks for asking
it's when you leave and you walk down
the hall to your offices and you keep
talking
and decisions are being made it's having
lunch together it's bumping to each
other in the hallway or at the copy
machine
it's all of the in-between things that
build trust it's like a relationship
like you know our spouses didn't fall in
love with us because
uh when we were at on the date or when
we remembered their birthday or
valentine's day
it happened in between it's how we
conduct ourselves and how we treat each
other
you know on when i go to the fridge and
i get a
drink for myself i bring you one as well
without you asking it's these little
things that happen between the big
events
and so i think that going back to the
office it's that fabric that holds us
together
nothing replaces human contact nothing
we can mitigate it for a while we can
drag it out for a while
but at the end of the day um uh human
human contact and human interaction is
where it's at